[Applauso]
[Musica]
sapevate che
se piegarsi questo foglio per 42 volte
potremmo scalarlo e arrivare alla luna
se non mi credete
adesso vi spiego lo spessore di questo
foglio di circa 0.1 mm questo vuol dire
che se lo piegasse arriveremo ad uno
spessore di 0.2 mm poi piegandolo ancora
0.4 poi 0.8 1.6 e così via
questo vuol dire che se riuscisse a
piegarlo per circa 11 volte arriverai ad
avere uno spessore e grande quanto circa
la mia mano dunque 12 volte sarebbe il
doppio 13 così 14 ancora di più
e così in crescita esponenziale dunque
se riuscissi a piegarlo per 22 volte
arriveremo ad avere uno spessore pari
all'altezza dell'empire state building
se riuscisse piegarlo per 32 volte
arriveremmo alla stazione spaziale
internazionale
e se infine riuscissi a piegarlo per 42
volte potremmo arrivare fino alla luna
ma non solo
se riuscissimo poi a piegarlo ancora e
ancora fino a 100 due volte arriveremo
ad uno spessore di 93 miliardi di anni
luce pari alla lunghezza dell'intero
universo osservabile quello che ho
appena raccontato è uno dei primissimi
video che ho pubblicato sul tic toc tic
toc il social network che di cui
sentiamo parlare spessissimo alla radio
dei giovani e della musica dei balletti
nel quale ci sembra che ci siano un
sacco di cose divertenti
ma nel quale evidentemente anche la
scienza funziona e così ha pubblicato
questo video in cui il fine era proprio
di spiegare la crescita fortissima della
funzione esponenziale diventato davvero
molto bene avuto più di quasi 2 milioni
di visualizzazioni l migliaia di
commenti mi ha fatto capire che si
poteva provare a fare un po di
divulgazione scientifica
anche perché credo che sia proprio molto
importante è non solo sentire parlare di
scienza ma anche capire davvero perché
e così iniziato a fare questi video
pubblicato moltissimi video da come
risolvere nel consiglio in primo grado a
che cos'è il gatto di schrodinger o
anche cose più curiose tipo
sapevate che usiamo un buco del naso
alla volta fatti se provate a tapparvi
un'area c'e respirare e poi a tapparvi
l'altra vi renderete conto che ce n'è
sempre una un po più aperto dell'altra
questo non è perché abbiamo tutti i set
da una trave deviato ma perché il nostro
cervello ogni tre ore ci fa riposare una
reach e quindi se provate ad esso e
riprovate alla fine di questo evento vi
accorgerete che è la narice più libera
sarà quella opposta benissimo in ogni
caso oggi non sono qui per raccontarvi
della mia avventura su tik tok anche
perché ho appena cominciato ci sono
persone molto più avanti di me nel
portare contenuti in internet
però vorrei provare a fare quello che
sto facendo su tik tok e cioè provare a
spiegare un qualche concetto scientifico
e per farlo capire davvero perché
appunto credo che non solo sia bello
informarsi sentir parlare di scienza
meccanica quantistica il big bang ma
anche se credo che sia molto importante
capire davvero i concetti uno alla volta
per riuscire a capire sempre di più il
mondo che ci circonda e dunque oggi
vorrei raccontarvi di uno dei concetti
che nella mia carriera accademica ne ha
più
fra tutti affascinato voi lo conoscete
sicuramente ormai hanno fatto che
vediamo davvero ovunque
però oggi vorrei provare a spiegarvi
davvero un concetto molto semplice della
teoria della relatività in particolare
la dilatazione del tempo nella teoria
della relatività ristretta
dunque oggi parleremo di tempo perché
tutti noi conosciamo il tempo ma in
realtà ha delle proprietà davvero molto
curiose che non conosciamo ma che spero
di farvi capire dunque partiamo allora
se vi chiedessi di rappresentare il
tempo come lo fareste molti
risponderebbero un orologio una
clessidra però parere comune potrebbe
vedere il tempo come una sorta di grande
massimo orologio che scocca i secondi
per tutti allo stesso modo quindi il
tempo passa per tutti continuamente
sempre allo stesso modo
la realtà però non è così
il tempo non scorre per tutte lo stesso
modo era so vi spiegherò perché nella
teoria della relatività infatti è stato
scoperto che il tempo e lo spazio che
fino a prima consideravamo come assoluti
uguali per tutti è assolutamente fermi
nell'universo non sono assoluti ma sono
creativi dipendono appunto teoria della
relatività da alcuni fattori esterni e
l'unica cosa costante nell'universo è
semplicemente la velocità della luce la
luce va sempre a circa 300.000
chilometri al secondo
chiunque la stia guardando che sia fermo
che stia correndo che sia in movimento
da ovunque la luce nel vuoto va sempre
alla stessa velocità
ora vi chiedo di ricordarvi bene questo
concetto che la luce per chiunque va
sempre alla stessa velocità adesso
facciamo uno step in avanti vorrei fare
con voi un piccolo esperimento mentale
dovete immaginare di entrare con me in
un treno a d'ora in poi le slide alle
oggi disegnate io dunque livello grafico
sarà davvero altissimo noi siamo dentro
un treno in realtà non ho neanche
disegnato il personaggio e noi siamo
dentro a questo treno questo treno sta
andando a cento all'ora però per noi che
siamo seduti dentro essendo che va a
velocità costante noi possiamo stare
seduti leggere un libro a parlare con le
persone intorno a noi
improvvisamente decidiamo di alzarci
guardiamo il fondo del vagone e ci
mettiamo a correre ma in questa corsa
corriamo a circa 50 chilometri all'ora
siamo ben allenati e percorriamo 10
metri
i 10 metri del vagone ok questa è una
cosa che abbiamo fatto tutti magari non
correndo però alzarci e andare verso
luce del treno abbiamo fatto tutti
magari qualcuno di voi l'ha fatto anche
oggi
ecco ora step2 di questo piccolo
esperimento poi capirete perché ve ne
sto parlando
immaginate una persona in stazione
mentre voi siete nel vostro treno il
treno non si ferma in quella stazione
quindi la persona a estrazione vede
passare il treno mentre voi state
correndo
dentro questo treno quindi il tema si
sposta mentre voi corrette
questo punto lo da mandare a che
velocità di vede passare quella persona
beh la risposta è facile a 150 km
all'ora
perché i 100 km del treno che si sta
spostando e 50 km di noi che stiamo
correndo
e quanto spazio ci ha visto fare la
persona fuori dal treno
beh 30 metri i 10 metri della nostra
corso nel vagone più di 20 metri per il
fatto che il 3 non si stava
effettivamente spostando per è che fin
qui è tutto abbastanza chiaro cosa che
abbiamo un vissuto tutti nella nostra
quotidianità
adesso però inizia il bello cambiamo
treno questo treno è un terno super
tecnologico e va a ben 250.000
chilometri al secondo
ok forse non abbiamo ancora tre anni
così veloci però immaginiamo di averlo
noi siamo dentro questo treno questo
treno va a velocità costante quindi come
prima sebbene siamo quasi alla velocità
della luce
per me che siamo dentro realtà cambia
poco e stiamo seduti possiamo leggere
giornali e parlare con le persone
intorno a noi dopo di che a un certo
punto
tiriamo fuori dalla tasca un laser il
classico laser tipo questo qui la lucina
rossa che che parte diciamo quasi
istantaneamente la puntiamo verso il
fondo del treno e facciamo partire
questo fascio di luce
a questo punto come prima al posto della
corsa abbiamo fatto correre la luce a
che velocità andava alla luce beh ne ho
visto prima a 300.000 chilometri al
secondo
e quanto spazio al percorso 10 metri
benissimo anche qua ci siamo ora step
successivo come prima è la persona in
stazione cosa vedrà di questo fascio di
luce beh come prima il treno non si
ferma e mentre il treno passa facciamo
partire il fascio di luce
a rigor di logica ci verrebbe da pensare
che la persona in stazione e del fascio
di luce come prima andare a 550 mila
chilometri al secondo cioè la somma di
250.000 chilometri al secondo che è a
versare il treno più di 300 della luce
quindi intuitivamente ci verrebbe da
pensare è questo quello che si vede la
realtà però non è così perché come ho
detto prima la luce
sempre e per chiunque a 300.000
chilometri al secondo
quindi qua c'è qualcosa di strano
l'altra cosa che comunque la persona che
ha fuori dal treno vede la luce per
correre comunque 30 metri quindi i 10
del vagone più il fatto che il treno si
è spostato a questo punto effettivamente
c'è qualcosa che non torna perché
ricapitolando la persona dentro al 39
della luce andare a 300.000 cremati al
secondo e fare dieci metri quella fuori
dal treno ad aver andare alla stessa
velocità ma fare trenta metri e dunque
dov'è l'inghippo
beh ora vi faccio vedere una formula è
l'unica formula che vi mostro prometto
ed è velocità uguale a spazio fratto
tempo
il fatto è che se la velocità deve
rimanere costante quindi sia la velocità
veloce nella natura è sempre costante
e se per un evento lo spazio aumenta
cioè da una parte su undici metri
dall'altra parte sono trenta metri
questo vuol dire che per forza di cose
per far sì che questa formula rimanga
effettivamente la realtà è pure il tempo
deve aumentare
dunque l'evento che dentro al treno dura
un secondo fuori dal treno invece durerà
tre secondi
questa cosa sembra paradossale ma la
realtà lo stesso evento per due
osservatori diversi impiega tempi
diversi
questa è la realtà nel quale viviamo
tutti i giorni noi non ce ne accorgiamo
perché ci sembra quasi paradossale ma
realtà anche mentre io cammino dentro
questo cerchio o anche mentre prima
correvo dentro al treno il tempo per me
era leggermente più lento rispetto al
tempo che passava fuori non c'è una
causa ma appunto perché sono frazioni di
secondo però la realtà è così il tempo
non è assoluto il tempo non passa per
tutti allo stesso modo non è un'entità
che scorre il tempo una proprietà di
ognuno di noi e questa non è filosofia
proprio fisica e scoperte fatte questo
scoperto avevo detto beh ma restiamo le
e dunque abbiamo provato non io
personalmente a prendere degli orologi
atomici e vedere se era effettivamente
così
dunque abbiamo preso un orologio atomico
super preciso l'abbiamo messo un aereo
poi un altro orologio sincronizzato
l'abbiamo tenuto a terra
abbiamo letto benissimo
se questa teoria è vera dopo aver fatto
fare a questo era un viaggio dovrebbe
atterrare trovarsi un paio di anticipo
vediamo se effettivamente funziona e
così è stato
dopo il viaggio aereo atterrato si è
trovato con un cinquantesimo di secondo
di anticipo
poca roba sì però dimostrato che
effettivamente il tempo passa in modo
diverso per tutti è così lo stesso
accade ad esempio nella stazione
spaziale internazionale
gli astronauti sono effettivamente i più
grandi viaggiatori nel tempo che abbiamo
e sulla terra e ma non solo questa cosa
è molto curiosa e affascinante è anche
davvero utile perché ad esempio e gps
che noi abbiamo nei nostri telefoni
senza le correzioni relativistiche data
dal fatto che il tempo nei satelliti che
gira che girano è diverso rispetto al
nostro tempo
noi non avremo dei gps così precisi
quindi tutte queste scoperte
scientifiche non solo solo fine a se
stesse anzi ci permettono da un lato di
comprendere davvero come funziona il
mondo
dall'altro lato anche di fare delle
scoperte tecnologiche e delle invenzioni
tecnologiche davvero davvero importanti
bene io spero di avervi fatto capire
questo piccolo concetto che appunto non
è magia ma è semplicemente fisica e
appunto come sto cercando di fare su tic
toc di portare piccoli concetti e non
solo raccontare le cose affascinanti ma
anche far capire perché e spero appunto
che comunque l'esempio dell'ex treno voi
abbiate potuto capire perché il tempo
passa in modo diverso proprio perché la
luce è l'unica costante dell'universo
però prima di lasciarvi con un sorriso
vi lascio anche con una citazione che mi
è sempre piaciuta davvero molto lui è
mago merlino che nella spada nella
roccia
dissi a segno da questo concetto che per
me davvero molto importante dice
ricordatevi che per quanto possiate
essere tristi per quanto le cose possano
andare mai per quanto possono togliere
di tutto quello che avete nessuno potrà
mai togliermi quello che avete imparato
perciò quando siete tristi imparate che
sia la teoria della relatività o come
impiegare un foglio di carta
grazie
[Applauso]